all the up and down your forecast a
gorgeous day tomorrow yeah it's still
nice and mild can you believe it for a
few days here before those temperatures
come crashing down
yet again 60 degrees today put us a few
digits above
normal 51 overnight for the low of
course we had all that cloud cover
overnight and
even though sprinkles early this morning
and also yesterday too
55 right now in sky canyon centenni
hills right at 50 even
aliante you're at 56 58 right now for
north las vegas
we're in the low 60s for sunrise manor
same goes for whitney ranch and green
valley 53 henderson
and mountains edge at 54 along with
southern highlands and again we'll
always switch up
our neighborhoods for you every newscast
so nobody is left
out how about prompt you're 56 right now
52 for boulder city
loughlin checking in at 63 degrees see
the spin in the atmosphere right here
that's the low near baja
and it is bringing some rainfall into
the southern portions of california
there but we're not going to get into
that anymore that's pretty much over and
done with
this will continue to move its way
eastward and of course we have several
systems two of them actually to talk
about
that are in the pipeline up here in the
pacific that are going to tap into that
cold arctic air there in alaska and then
move its way down towards us that's
going to drop our temperatures big time
this weekend and especially next
week so there's one i pinpointed out
here that's moving out here's the second
one
for weekend showers and also wind
and then with this one behind that's
going to pull out some colder air
and bring us some snow in the mountains
for sure and maybe even some
low elevation snow or even some flurries
we'll talk about that in a bit wind
forecast though shows
those gusty winds expected on friday
decreasing a little on saturday
breezy monday and tuesday with that
second system i talked about a pair of
them
right now that we're tracking 43 degrees
overnight mostly clear
and of course drier after those
sprinkles we had this morning we'll take
any raindrops we can get all right
65 degrees for tomorrow sunny and milder
for tomorrow with your temperatures look
at that above average
60 or 59 is where we should be and
temperatures will be in those mid 60s so
let's take a look at what to expect for
your weekend
as we are actually our temperatures for
tomorrow we should say in the mid 60's
for us for tomorrow for centennial hills
summerlin at 62. now your extended
forecast
more clouds friday with wind there's a
temperature drop saturday with those
slight shower chances
and then look at next week all right
we're eyeing the possibility look at
your overnight lows that's going to be
near freezing
you're throwing a little bit of precip
in there too and some of that could
change over to flurry so we'll be
watching that
for specifically tuesday morning and
monday night
we'll have more details on that coming
up in just a couple minutes in the
meantime brian wilson back over here all
right ted thank